For more than 40 years, CNN has offered
a front row
seat to history in the making.
Why am I under arrest?
It's a hoax set up.
Join us
as we turn back the clock to expose
Osama bin Laden
and watch the stories
that have defined our time
There are no words to say O.J.
Simpson
This is CNN's Rewind
It was January 1991.
The U.S.
economy was sinking into recession.
Mob boss John Gotti,
the Teflon Don,
had recently been arrested on charges
that would lead to life imprisonment.
Macaulay Culkin
faced off with criminals
in the first home alone.
And President George H.W.
Bush edged
towards war in the Persian Gulf.
Then one early January
morning in Baghdad,
CNN reported that the skies over Baghdad
have been illuminated with big
plans and missiles set up.
And an explosive development near
the Persian Gulf.
Word that Iraq has invaded neighboring
state of Kuwait,
where fighting reported along the border.
The residents say that
they were awakened by machine gunfire
and heavy artillery for weeks.
100,000 Iraqi troops have been reported
massing near the border.
Arab countries
have been trying this month
to diffuse this building crisis.
In Washington,
the White House is condemning
the invasion,
calling for Iraq
to withdraw its forces immediately.
The U.S.
is also calling for an emergency. U.N.
Security Council session.
The Security Council passed sanctions.
No more trade with Iraq.
A boycott of Iraqi oil.
A ban on arms sales.
A ban on financial aid and investment.
But will the sanctions work?
Today, America
stops mulling over its options,
reportedly
sending United States warplanes
and combat troops into Saudi Arabia.
We seek the immediate,
unconditional and complete withdrawal
of all Iraqi forces from Kuwait.
From the beginning of the Gulf crisis.
The underlying rationale
for stopping Saddam Hussein has been oil.
The oil dependent world
doesn't want a single man
with a big army
to control the flow from the Gulf
With the Operation Desert Shield deadline
less than three weeks away.
Diplomats and journalists
are ready to leap
at any trace of activity
that might lead to the bargaining table
unless Saddam Hussein
withdraws from Kuwait by late winter.
The U.S.
will go to war
The Bush White House
now says war with Iraq
could begin at any moment.
It took six months to come to this.
But as our senior
White House
correspondent Charles Bierbauer reports,
President Bush
believed early on in this crisis
that it would ultimately be settled
with force
White House officials
say even now,
Saddam Hussein
could avoid a war
with a massive pullout of his forces.
And yet
the Bush administration
does not expect that
Good evening or rather,
good morning from Saudi Arabia,
where it's now a quarter
after two in the morning.
The latest briefing
we've received
from the military command here in Saudi
Arabia was on the number of troops here.
And apparently
there's a total of 425,000 U.S.
troops here.
That's an increase of 10,000 over
the last time we were briefed.
The total multinational force
here on the ground is about 690,000
With us
now is Caspar Weinberger,
secretary of defense
during both Reagan administrations.
Mr. Secretary, thank you for coming.
Thank you.
Secretary one
where you were credited
with the military buildup, which
is being put to use.
But there is one
area which which has come to
a lot of criticism.
We have to go to Baghdad. Secretary.
We're going to Bernard Shaw in Baghdad.
This is
something is happening outside of the
Peter Arnett.
Join me here.
What let's describe to our viewers
what we're seeing.
The skies over
Baghdad have been illuminated.
We're seeing bright flashes
going off all over the sky, Peter.
Well, there's anti-aircraft
gunfire going into the sky.
However, we have not yet heard
the sound of bombs landing,
but there's tremendous
lightning in the sky.
I have a sense, Peter,
that people are shooting towards the sky
and they are not aware
or cannot see what they're shooting at.
This is extraordinary.
We're getting starbursts
seeming starbursts in the black sky.
We have not heard any jet planes yet.
Peter
No point.
Now the sirens are
sounding for the first time.
The Iraqis have informed us
Well, we heard
Peter Arnett saying
the Iraqis have informed us
and then we didn't hear any more.
This is probably just a technical glitch.
They have four wires there
that they can use
and those wires can be easily
severed or pulled.
Wolf, what have you for us
at this moment?
There is strong indications
here at the Pentagon
that this war may be beginning right now
and that the president
may be going on
television later
this evening to explain
what exactly is going on.
Wolf, let me just let me interrupt.
I'm sorry to interrupt,
but we're going back to Baghdad now
because we can
and we have people are not out far away,
but we are sending to them.
Please come in to us from Baghdad.
This is David French in Washington.
Well, Baghdad cruise lines, did
they just cut the line
All right.
We've lost that for the moment.
Back to the Pentagon again.
Wolf,
you were just reporting
that there is new activity level.
Hello, Atlanta.
Atlanta, this is Holliman.
I don't know whether you think
you're able to hear me now or not,
but I'm going to continue to talk to you
as long as I can.
There have been some sirens here tonight,
but we are we still have seen
no sign of any airplanes coming in here.
All we are seeing is the
the Iraqi response from the ground, many,
many troops around that.
You can
perhaps
hear the sound of bombs
in the background and all that.
I've got a microphone out the window.
I think you'll be able to hear the sound
from
the night sky of Baghdad
time here
about 20 minutes ago,
three in the morning.
I'm getting away from there,
from the windows.
I'm going to turn off the microphone
for one moment
in an attempt
to see if we can
we can hear Atlanta
and not get some response from
CNN down the line.
All right.
We're not immediately
able to pick up
to resume that sound
from John Holman's position.
So we will now return to the Pentagon,
where Wolf
Blitzer has some more for us Wolf.
Yes, David, only moments ago,
before I came into the studio
here at the Pentagon,
I had a chance
to see two very senior Pentagon officials
almost running through the halls,
going up to Secretary Cheney's office.
Let's go back to Baghdad
and see what John Holliman
is reporting in the meantime.
There's a response here,
as if the city were under attack,
the night sky filled with them
with a hail of bullets
and from anti-aircraft guns.
And up in the distance,
you can hear what appears to be
bombs of some kind,
hitting the ground or perhaps
artillery shells hitting the ground.
They're allowed reports
and you can feel the
the building
of this
very well, Bill, hotel shaking underneath
as the heavy attack apparently continues.
Hi there.
Is it possible to call
the United States, please,
back in an
open microphone
from Baghdad, from the hotel,
now being a hotel room, now being left,
we believe, by Bernard Shaw,
Peter Arnett,
John Holliman and Anderson Porter
support staff there.
There is a bomb shelter in that hotel.
We heard them report earlier today.
Back to the Pentagon and Wolf Blitzer.
David, all day long,
we've been hearing rumors
that the attack would start at night,
Baghdad time,
that the attack,
if it did
come, would try to take advantage of U.S.
night fighting equipment
especially with the radar
evading stealth fighters.
And that is backed up by indications
that we're getting here in the Pentagon.
The stepped up activity
among the senior civilian
and military staff
Wolf, we can still hear
John Holliman in Baghdad
and we'll go listen in.
He can't hear me, but we can hear him.
All right.
We're told,
David, a miracle has happened.
We are now able to hear you as well.
My colleague
Peter Arnett and I are here at our CNN
Baghdad bureau.
You have no idea,
David French,
how nice it is to hear your voice on this
remarkable night.
Peter, let's let's tell our viewers
what what's happened here.
You've had a lot of experience with
with being under attack.
Of course, in Vietnam and other places.
The antiaircraft weapons
in the city center
where we are living around the government
buildings erupted and fires.
I must have been 200 guns firing
to the sky.
We did not see
any aircraft around,
but we did hear the alarm sirens.
About 2 minutes after that,
there were loud explosions
and obviously
bombing in at least three parts
of the outskirts of the city.
We have no idea what those targets were,
but they were in the direction
of the airport
and some military barracks
And the
bombing has not come in this far yet.
The attack did begin about 2:30 a.m.
our time now
here in the hotel,
the Al-Rasheed Hotel, where we are.
There was some indication
earlier this evening
some of our colleagues
received calls
from friends who said tonight,
maybe the night Peter the
for the multinational force
to begin at strike,
Peter O'Neill had to strike against Iraq.
And tonight it has come John.
That's right, Peter.
I think it would be good for those of us
in Baghdad
to turn off our microphone
for just a moment.
We have our CNN colleagues,
of course, all over the world.
Perhaps, David, France
may be able to tell us as much about
what they know
about this potential attack
as we can tell.
Looking out our window,
John,
I think you might have thrown it to me.
I couldn't tell.
But if you did,
we have a radio pool report in from
John Bascom.
He's reporting that a squadron of F-15
fighter
bombers has taken off
from a base in central Saudi Arabia.
The fighter is designed
for a long range bombing at night
where completely loaded with bombs,
according to this report, with missiles
and with 20 millimeter guns.
I was looking out the window
earlier, John and oh, Peter,
look over here.
There is a sky is lighting up,
I guess, to the south.
So that aircraft fire some as bright
red other as flashes of yellow light.
What seems clear is
that city is well defended
with that aircraft fire.
And we can only presume
that because they have started up again
with considerable rapidity
that there is another attack coming in.
We just heard, Wolf.
Holy cow.
That was a large airburst that we saw.
There was a feeling the sky was not.
And I think, John, that airburst took out
the telecommunications
that you might hear a lot about.
If you're still with us,
you're going to hear the bombs.
Now, they are hitting
the center of the city.
Where crowds find a window and a hill.
We're about three miles
from where
the center of action at this point
seems to be.
It's good to have a colleague
like Peter Arnett to help out.
I'll tell you that
by my experience
of being under attack is very limited,
I'm proud to say.
But I think by the time
the sun comes up
tomorrow,
my experience will be much improved
in this regard.
We have a
cameraman, Mark Biello,
by the way, is taking pictures of this
and is doing
we're able
to establish a
video link to you,
which we're sure won't be anytime soon.
But will be hours from now,
will be able to show you the pictures
that we're talking about right now.
John and Peter,
we're going to the White House
for just a minute.
Presidential spokesman
Marlin Fitzwater is about to address
the nation and therefore the world
I have a statement by
the president of the United States
The liberation of Kuwait has begun
in conjunction
with the forces
of our coalition partners.
The United States has moved
under the codename Operation Desert Storm
to enforce the mandates
of the United Nations Security Council
as a 7:00 p.m.
Eastern Standard Time, Operation Desert
Storm forces were engaging targets
in Kuwait and Iraq.
President Bush
will address the nation at 9:00 p.m.
tonight from the Oval Office.
I'll try to get you more
as soon as we can.
Thank you very much, Carol.
There we go.
Okay, Peter, we're back.
I think what is most interesting to me,
John, is that these bombs came
right on target during the Vietnam War.
There was a major problem
with bombing
targets in North Vietnam,
and many bridges survived for years.
Tonight, every bomb we've seen line
seem to have hit something.
They have the laser directed
the way the guided
bomb systems
now, which seem to be proving
effective here tonight.
We've been waiting for this to happen
since the deadline on the U.N.
ultimatum passed at 8:00 yesterday
morning in Baghdad.
And certainly as the day progressed,
it was clear here
that the authorities seemed
to be preparing for some kind of action.
I'm sure they didn't have
any kind of advance word.
But as I speak to you,
the antiaircraft
fire has started up again.
And there is another wave of planes
presumably coming in.
We have yet to see the bombs fall,
that it's the same pattern
that the previous
at least three raids
that we have witnessed
Wherever you are
following CNN's coverage of this.
Our colleagues in Washington
and our colleagues in Saudi Arabia
obviously know a lot more than we know.
But we are on the receiving end of it.
I just want to add one thing
to everybody that we are safe, relatively
speaking, Peter.
And there is no sense of
an immediate threat to our lives.
You can go with that.
I would concur that.
I think we're safe enough here
for the time being.
Within a minute,
we can get to a shelter downstairs.
John, it occurs to me that this attack
is going to just shake
the psyches of the Baghdadi's here.
This is
unprecedented,
and I'm really anxious
for daybreak to come
so that
we can get out
and see what has been wrought here.
All right.
DAYBREAK is only 4 hours away.
And if we make it
that long,
we'll certainly be able to do that.
Richard Blystone is standing by
in Jerusalem.
The streets are unnaturally quiet.
The Israeli government,
of course, does know about it.
The prime
minister says he has been informed
the military will be making a statement
very soon.
The radio here now is
is broadcasting CNN live.
The foreign ministry
also is watching CNN.
A lot of people
now are getting their news from CNN
Something has changed over.
All the lights in the city of Baghdad
are now out from everything we can tell.
My colleague
Bernie Shaw is with me
as we look out
in the now dark city
it's absolutely pitch black.
We are confined to the hotel.
We can give this report tonight
because we're on the ninth floor
of the Al-Rashid Hotel,
which has a commanding view
of this
very flat city to the north,
south, east and west.
And for about the last 2 hours,
there has been enormous activity.
And now we hear planes
actually going over here Yeah.
Well, I'll see if I can see anything.
All right.
The plane there, by burning this up,
right?
It's broken out on either side of us
here at the hotel.
And I'm just going to
be quiet and let you listen
This is the heaviest rate
so far, so close in.
Maybe the outskirts
have been pounded this way,
but certainly several planes came
right over the hotel
and hit targets
within a mile and a half of us.
Bernie, what do you see
in the other side of the hotel?
I just come back from the other side.
I'm really wearing our trousers
here, crawling on my knees and hands
like gentleman.
Does it occur to you
that it is not accidental,
that we are still reporting to the world?
This government has
a has told us frequently,
including the information minister
last night, that he wanted the press
to stay here.
In fact, he expressed anger
that some of the press had left.
He said
The international press said
it covers human rights.
It should be here to see what
the United States,
the multinational force is going to do.
Now, I don't see any government
officials around here tonight
to assist us,
but they have said that
we can work here and up to now.
This has to be unique
that we are continuing
to cover this story, to talk to you.
Despite a series of major
impact bombing raids.
Well, I'm anxious for daylight to come.
Maybe we can get some visibility.
You know, look at this.
This is a bright flash of light
that seems to be
it came across from north to south
and even came up here by us in a hotel.
And there it goes
by almost like a shooting star.
But I think that shooting star
is probably intensifying on air
Just one comment.
Clearly, I've never been there,
but this feels like
we're in the center of hell.
We have temporarily lost contact
with Baghdad.
I don't wish to alarm anyone.
We did expect to have this
come in and out.
But our three correspondent
Bernard Shaw,
Peter Arnett and John Holliman
are there in the Al Rasheed Hotel.
We expect to
and we hope to be bringing you
some more of their reports later
I'm pleased to report
that we can go back to Baghdad now
and our three correspondents there.
Let's see who picks up the phone
just to explain to our viewers
why you did not hear from us for
a nervously long time.
For the past 20 minutes,
I've been hiding under a table.
And what happened was
the security people made a sweep.
They got very upset
that there were
three mortars on this floor,
just three men standing in a hotel room.
So I scampered to hide to make sure
that if they pulled Arnett and Holman out
and took them downstairs,
indicated
they at least there would still be one
CNN person on the air, John.
The same thing you did, Bernie, on air.
I hid under a bed.
And it's amazing that somebody large
is able
to get under a bed
that close to the ground.
But I was able to do it at least.
And the security guards
also took some of the videotape
out of one of our cameras.
We basically will get it back tomorrow.
I'm a little skeptical that we will,
but it was the beautiful pictures
that we took to go
along with the commentary
that you heard earlier tonight on CNN.
You keep using that word beautiful.
It is not beautiful to me.
Yes.
2 hours ago,
Allied air forces began
an attack on military targets
in Iraq, in Kuwait,
These attacks continue as I speak.
Ground forces are not engaged tonight.
28 nations.
Countries from five continents,
Europe and Asia, Africa
and the Arab League
have forces in the Gulf area
standing shoulder to shoulder against
Saddam Hussein.
These countries had hoped
the use of force could be avoided.
Regrettably, we now believe
that only force will make him leave
I've told the American people before
that this will not be another Vietnam.
And I repeat this here tonight.
Our troops will have the best
possible support in the entire world,
and they will not be asked to fight.
With one hand tied behind their back
we have no argument
with the people of Iraq.
Indeed, for the innocents
caught in this conflict,
I pray for their safety.
Our goal
is not the conquest of Iraq.
It is the liberation of Kuwait.
In Iran and Baghdad, Iraq.
17 hours after the bombing
focused on the Alamo,
as Bernie
Shaw and myself, Peter Arnett,
who is signing off from Baghdad for CNN.
And I hope we can resume
our communication with you
in the very near future.
The best reporting that
I've seen on what transpired in
Baghdad is on CNN.
In West Berlin.
Jason?
There are no words,
no history, United States.
Osama bin Laden, you exclusion.
Donald Trump wins.
It's a hoax. Why am I under arrest?